hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to SCP containment
breach I cannot see a damn thing
I would have started back to where I was
before I was a little disoriented
because ah it's been a while I can't
remember where I've been and that's mr.
reptilian man's room now I have had the
damnedest I'm trying to actually get a
video up today so hopefully this one
actually works I can't see a damn thing
you guys missed the jump scare of the
centuries because I've been trying to
record a whole bunch of things today but
I went through three different games
that were just so unbelievably bad that
I couldn't bring myself to post them or
even edit them and then I've tried to
record this twice now with two different
pieces of software I'm on my third one
right now and hopefully it's gonna give
me something because of quarter to full
episodes and we're fantastic but you
guys won't be able to see them so now
I'm a little stressed
I'm not playing this game again that I
don't remember where I was so you guys
get to experience the glory of that whoo
anyway that brings us up to where we are
now so let's play this game that I love
so much I swear every time I come back
into this game I forget everything
okay I'm not just for daesil what is
that get out my ears please he's cycling
around my ears like a douchey ghost
Oh God miss the place where makita's
working Hey oh the [ __ ] are you hello
I've never seen you in my goddamn life
so don't screw out of a - how are you
why were you dancing I've no idea what
that is but is it gone son of a [ __ ] I
see how you're playing I see your game
you rogue
so is that gonna be I've been just a
little bit stressed throughout my
attempts at making this game work
oh and the first time it crashed so I
didn't even get any of that yeah not
here not now not now I thought I already
experienced this Oh God I don't know
I can't believe we have to listen to the
skin how many times have the experiences
horror well now I know it awaits me as
per usual am I going there with full
confidence that I'm gonna be just fine
okay where is he in relation to
everything else God wasn't okay okay so
we're all there is good thing I'm not
looking at him
Oh looking on okay so here we go I hate
that part hate it hate this part I'm
gonna bump right into him aren't I all
right him well that's a big solid chunk
of man that I'm bumping into okay maybe
not it was a solid chunk of wall okay I
move gather way oh god this is horrible
oh okay dude time fuel pump
Hey
Oh God
Wow God who do I do Oh where's it done
so much son of a [ __ ] why would you
come and fail affair oh god I'm getting
sent in I thought he was just gonna kill
me why you gotta be such a big hole well
they haven't been here in a while so I'm
as I'll explore get the burn note so I
can have the stupid code to do the
stupid thing
maybe I'll get out alive this time maybe
this time everything's gonna be all
right
least I don't have to deal with douche
emic face don't look hello oh oh no no
no way he let me out you let me out that
early no way no way access code in three
two one Maynard no way no way let me out
wait there's some trick in okay there's
a drink it was a trick C trick
Oh God oh it's some kind of trick it's
trick it's all a trick whoa okay what's
this now
hello
let's look safe whoa what the hell oh
you got some new tricks up in his blue
got this I know this is yep okay this is
a swing Oh God
we go go go come on come on come on come
on come on faster oh good well at least
I'll be able to go home no in addition
to the decomposed appearance typically
the victims whose scp-106 the body
exhibits injuries that must have not
been observed before massive skull
fracture three broken ribs fractured
children multiple heavy lacerations
probably from a giant swinging hammer ax
god damn this came to hell and back it's
always got new surprise oh god I'm back
here honor
why didn't save where am I what is this
[ __ ] what he was posted this is
where I loaded up this isn't where I
saved I did not save in this dimension I
saved it somewhere else better not have
saved for me you bastard God not again
also now I'm in perpetual hell huh
it's gotta get close enough that it does
Hemi okay go don't don't don't don't
where I didn't see that one oh god I saw
that one now okay that one goes quicker
well it's two of them oh god I'm dead
okay okay don't make me do this again
I don't want finish again I swear to God
I did not save in here right a glare you
being a bit of a son of a [ __ ] you
don't you just let me go on home now
once you just let me go on home huh
there's gonna be a lot of bodies to be
found once I go home oh I can't see a
damn thing
ah there's nothing there it's a whole
lot of nothing just emptiness oh my god
okay did it bug out or is this what it's
supposed to be I cannot see I can't see
okay all right I'm assuming that it
bugged out drop me through the floor
it's only logical oh god I can see
something I can like just I can like
just barely make out something maybe I'm
crazy yeah I'm crazy okay I'm outta here
guys again I'm not afraid I said I'm not
afraid
yeah shut up don't talk about my dreams
like that ah coming okay here we go this
is as bad as it was before so now now
now oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god
it's coming it's coming go go go go go
go friggin you
okay I'm dead I'm dead okay hey skip
I hate it so much I don't want to go
back in I even want to go back in
well alright then fine good
Oh God devil stick stupid piece crap ass
piece [ __ ] my last poop oh where am I
now please tell me one of these hallways
leads to something other than a swinging
ball of death they all in the swingin
balls of death don't a joke Johnny on
jump it off OOP pander pander planner
Wayne or am I now
oh I'm dead well same to have several
multiple a/b fractures of both of his
legs
good good good that's good so jumping
off isn't an option I wish I could be
able to make it through these things but
oh god please stop the risk Ray Lewis
ring does not help me at all believe it
or not I don't look okay
believe it or not I don't like your
company gotta go out again
tries again if I could just get through
the goddamn area with Oh nine six I
don't even think oh nine to six is my
problem anymore I just need to worry
about radical air being the biggest
[ __ ] in the history of [ __ ] don't
look at me like that don't look at me
I'm not a failure out of failure
I'm a little bit of Israeli go
why didn't that work
ah yeah I'm going back screw you guys
I'm out of here
where'd it go where'd it go oh god damn
it screw you I'm uh okay screw you I'm
flying I'm flying we okay so no clip
whatever you know what I did it it
didn't do it because it's a douche I did
it I did it
I'm not going down there knowing he'll
love it
okay go ahead finally one that's not an
elevator down to hell where am I now
oh um places I've been before
Oh how the hell did this loop back to
where I've been before you sack of crap
you son of a [ __ ] you piece of ass you
better be gone better be gone I'm gonna
hand her my way back to health
I'm gonna go down one he's got damn
elevators question is which one okay so
if I go through that's definitely a way
I'm not bad before so fine fine I chose
the same
paste noodle hope okay what we got oh oh
nightmares awesome so what are we
dealing with this time zombo's
Zimbabwe's what are we dealing with
looks like zombies definitely zombies
I smell zombies I'm gonna assume it's
not gonna bug out like you did last time
it's actually gonna come kill me
it's definitely what's gonna happen yeah
elevator power feed generator power
don't come hear me where am i where am i
where am i I'm sorry sorry sir okay I
don't hear him I'm just under there so
did he sighs like any day now
oh I gotta go back I think those another
switch I didn't throw sneakin I'm a
sneaky sneaker I'm so sneekly don't wa
don't my neighbor greetings oh how are
you Oh what are you doing no no you were
doing that before don't you run cool
alright this game is just as big a dick
as it always is saamana finish this in
another episode make some actual
progress so thank you everybody so much
for watching click the annotation for a
lot more SCP containment breach that I
played in the past and as always I will
see you in the next video
what's up